also the arm's kind of going woke oh man
oh man and this is this is the thing
we've been talking about right man it's
like inclusion can we just focus on
[__] works can we focus on what works
right I want the Army to be good at
killing the enemy I don't give a [__]
about how diverse they are right imagine
if the UFC had to have
diversity do you know what a problem
that would be we had like to have a
certain amount of trans folks a certain
amount of work well in the women's
division if you only
had like if you like you had numbers you
had to achieve it wouldn't wasn't the
best fighters it was just you know like
who meet certain criteria there's going
to be a bunch of people that get
murdered yeah they're going to get
thrown there with the real ones it's
going to be a certain percentage of
people that are just there because
they're awesome then a certain
percentage of people that they have to
hire in order to meet these Dei
standards Joe I'm going to Jamie can I
ask a favor man would you mind bringing
up uh RAF diversity UK you're going to
beautiful story this is a beautiful
story what
happened mate this is just look up for
male a white a useless male white Pilots
look that one up useless male white
Pilots was that a quote Yeah that's a
quote from their from their report they
they were like you know what we're not
hiring any more uh white men to fly
planes a good idea yeah definitely don't
hire the people that are the best at it
no why would whether they're white or
black or Asian no just don't hire white
ones Royal Air Force unlawfully
discriminated against white male
recruits in bid to boost diversity dude
you want the best whoever the [__] they
are whether they they're white or South
American or Indian or you want the best
who cares that's no one cares you want
people who fly the planes the best right
only the best and this is like
controversial now it's a war plane could
you imagine imagine if like again it
goes back to the MMA fighters imagine if
like you know like the UK had one
representative That was supposed to be
fighting Francis and ganu you know you
know what I'm saying pick me do you know
you have you have a you have one person
who supposed to step up and fight that
guy and uh well it says the right move
is to you know send in a non-binary
woman yeah because they don't get
represented in in the UFC like okay what
the [__] are you talking about this is
she's representing the UK we need
someone to go beat him man it's it comes
to a point and and this is where we talk
about the University campus right you
can have these demented ideas on a
University campus
and all they are is an exercise and
intellectual masturbation when you come
down to it when you break it down to its
purest sense right and in a way that's
fine what's wrong with having stupid
ideas and debating and believing it but
the problem is is when you start to
implement it in the real world where
there is such a thing as reality right
that's when the robber hits the road and
things really start going wrong that's
when things go Western that's what we
like to call it out here right things
got Western right I will say as well in
I think you know we've been talking
about social media I think social media
is a big part of this I don't know if
you've seen the graphs but basically
what happens in 2013
2014 newspaper articles just start that
all this social justice [__] it just
goes through the sky and not just in the
US and the UK it's Qatar it's it's every
country in the world so I think social
media rewards ideas that sound good it
does but it also Awards Echo Chambers
you know that's that's a big part of
just like we're talking about
universities that you know the echo on
the right wing online are just just like
the echo Chambers on the left ring it's
like it rewards that everybody looks for
their favorite commenters who jump on
their threads and comment on each and
every one and back them up on these
things and they look at all the likes
and yeah kicking ass